[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about hasta from black clover I
just want to say that I recently caught
up to the manga and there's no doubt
about it it is awesome at con Bravo this
year a fan actually asked us what we
thought of black clover because he loved
it I hadn't checked it out yet so I
couldn't give him a good answer then but
now I can honestly say that I love it
I had the same awesome and hyped up
emotions reading it that I felt more
than a decade ago when I first read
early Naruto if you're also a fan of
black clover and want to see more black
clover videos on this channel let me
know by smashing that like button using
the magic or anti magic of your choice
if you haven't make sure to hit that
like button and ring that magic youtube
bell to join the black bulls of youtube
now without further ado let's get into
some anti magical facts
fact number one hasta has been used in
some really cool crossover art for
instance black clover creator yuki
Tabata and my hero academia creator
Kohei horikoshi are friends and both
published their manga in the same
magazine the famous shounen jump in 2017
in a very special issue of Shonen Jump
Giga the two drew each other's
characters Tabata drew the cover of a my
hero academia vol showcasing deku Baku
go Todoroki and/or choco in his style in
contrast horikoshi drew the cover of a
black clover vol in his own style
drawing hasta you know and the well in
my hero academia fashion and of course
hasta is screaming on the cover as he
usually does you can let me know which
style you prefer but whichever it is I
think it is very interesting to see how
the respective styles differ even when
they're illustrating each other's
characters in addition to my hero
academia there has been crossover art
release that combines pasta with
elements from the legendary pirate king
of manga one piece for example on one
cover of shounen jump all
current major characters in drum
switched outfits Luffy Ward Dec ooze
hero costume while hasta war Luffy's
outfit
along with his signature straw hat could
this before shattering that black clover
will become the next pirate king of
manga I guess we'll have to wait and see
finally in the manga Tabata gave us some
sketches he did for weekly shonen jump
where he made a solo hasta for the cover
of one issue and then a normal hasta for
the next issue so that the two would
form a pair if you line them up I
totally get why they picked hasta to be
Zorro since they both fight with swords
have the same number of swords currently
and both have used their mouths to swing
a sword
I love swords personally and I gotta say
I love the fact that we have another
short main character they use a sword
for battle shout out to ichigo fact
number 2 in an interview tabata was
asked which of the characters in black
clover is most like him he answered
hasta and his editor Katayama said and i
quote
it's definitely austin tabitha sensei is
always super positive and can never be
still not that we needed a third source
to confirm this but fellow shounen jump
mangaka you hey
Tamura confirms it anyway tamara worked
with tabata as an assistant to toshiaki
yachiru the creator of siren so the two
got to know each other really well for
the second volume of black clover tamara
created a special support manga for
tabata on account of the success he's
been having with black clover in the
short manga Tamara illustrates the first
time they met and in this manga he pokes
fun at how similar Tabata is to his
character
hasta instead of drawing Tabata he
simply draws hasta and writes that
Tabata even when he was a newbie was
exactly like black clovers main
character interestingly enough for
Tabitha's first serialization in shounen
jump which was called hungry Joker
he had according to him a pretty quiet
character I read a few chapters and the
main character's personality was much
more like you knows and he was a genius
scientist to boot the complete opposite
of
stuff he liked the idea of having a
quieter more dark main character but the
audience didn't respond well and that
manga got canceled so then Tabitha
learned from that failure and made hasta
a more happy-go-lucky character that was
easier to understand
he also made hasta really energetic like
himself and other famous Shonen
protagonists like Luffy and Naruto
luckily fans responded great to the loud
and more straightforward hasta which
brings us to fact number three let's
talk about Austin's popularity although
hasta is the main character that doesn't
always translate to being the most
popular character if we look at my hero
academia Baku go the main characters
rival has come and first place more
times than deku in the Shonen Jump
popularity polls hasta however has
managed to stay ahead of his rival you
know in the first Japanese poll hasta
came in first with 2911 posts and almost
1,000 votes behind in second place was
the man who seems to always be taking a
dump at the wrong time Yami in the
second Japanese poll hasta got first
place again and the distance from second
place which was Yami again grew as well
so in Japan Austin seems to have an
exceptionally strong hold on people's
hearts even for a main character the
English polls were a bit different
though the captain of the black bulls
managed to finish in first place both
times and hasta finished right behind
him in second place both times while
best girl Noel mares to finish third
place both times nevertheless hasta is
clearly an extremely popular character
at least among black clover fans and
that doesn't surprise me one bit how can
you not love someone who decides that
he'll become the wizard king when he
doesn't even have any magic hasta gives
the characters in the story and us the
readers and Watchers a great example to
look up to Austin reminds us that we all
possess the magic of not giving up but
it's up to us whether we'll activate
that magic or negated fact number four
in the official data book Austin scored
the lowest cost
we'll score in everything that had to do
with magic
so in magic amount he scored a zero out
of five in magic control he scored
another zero and in magic sensing he
scored a third zero just to put this in
perspective you know scored a perfect
five in magic amount a strong foreign
magic control and another perfect five
in magic sensing clearly you know and
pretty much everyone else is more gifted
in magical abilities than hasta however
because hasta has so much trouble with
magic he decided that instead of whining
and doing nothing he would improve in
any way he could which meant training
his body as a result of this Austin
scored a very impressive five out of
five in physical strength he's one of
the physically strongest characters in
black clover thanks to his relentless
training on the other hand you know who
was blessed with amazing magical
abilities didn't feel the need to train
his body so in that area he scored less
than hasta a 3 out of 5 in cleverness
hasta scored a solid 4 out of 5 and his
bonus personalized measurement was
willpower and you can bet he score in a
perfect 5 out of 5 in that fact number 5
as with most manga before black clover
was serialized in Shonen Jump Tabata
created a one-shot manga it's pretty
much like a pitch for a manga series and
lucky for Tabata and for us people like
Tabitha's pitch although a lot of stuff
from the one shot was used in the
official manga there were some
interesting differences in the one shot
for instance there's no sister Lily in
the one shot instead of living in a
church Austin you know are in a magical
school surrounded by other magical
students kind of like Hogwarts since
Lily isn't in the picture you see hasta
confessing his feelings to a female
student but she flat-out rejects him so
yeah believe it or not Austin's favorite
person didn't exist in the one shot also
in the one shot hasta is not necessarily
an orphan
although we do not see his parents he
does have a last name stariha in
addition the villain in the one shot is
a noble student rather than a former
magic knight however despite the
differences Tabitha definitely stayed
true to the loudmouth magic list
hard-working and lovable auste from the
one shot fact number six you may be
surprised to learn that berserk the
mature dark fantasy manga was one of
Tabitha's biggest inspirations for black
clover but it's true in an interview he
said that with black clover he wanted to
make a manga like berserk but for the
Shonan demographic this made so much
sense to me when I discovered this
interview as I read the manga William
from Golden Dawn gave off an
unmistakable Griffith vibe and in the
interview Tabata acknowledges that
that's what he was going for with the
character you can see the influence of
berserk in other ways too
Belle is reminiscent of puck Sol is
reminiscent of Casca and Yami in many
ways is reminiscent of guts however
perhaps the most obvious nod to berserk
is the black bull swordsman hasta auste
like guts is extremely strong and uses a
giant heavy sword that most people would
have trouble even picking up as his
weapon of choice let me know if you
noticed any references to other anime or
movies in black clover fact number 7 in
the manga volumes there is something
similar to all this question corner in
the one piece volumes where the mangaka
answers fans questions except in this
case tabitha calls it the assorted
questions brigade rather than the
question corner there are sometimes very
interesting questions that are asked and
sometimes when respond to thank
questions tabitha ranked specific
characters in terms of what is being
asked these are my favorite questions
because you get to see how the
characters rank among each other when
measured by a specific criteria and
honestly who doesn't like ranking anime
characters and austin is often a part of
these rankings for example in volume 9
one fan asked who is the smartest member
of the black bolts instead of just
answering who's the smartest tubba to
rank the members I found it interesting
to learn that the nose bleeding mirror
using sister lover got first and the
murmuring Marilyn Manson
looking Gordon got second and hasta was
at the end of the list in 11th place so
even if he's talented at fighting hasta
is not the smartest among the group of
misfits but neither is Goku from Dragon
Ball Z or Naruto from you guessed it
Naruto but that's never held a shounen
protagonist back from doing the
impossible surpassing their limits and
making their dreams come true in fact
maybe not overthinking stuff is one of
Austin's strengths next in volume 10
someone asked for the physical strength
rankings for black clover characters and
although he was beaten by Yami who got
first place Austin managed to come in
second his physical training definitely
paid off since this is an insanely
impressive feat scoring second at his
young age of 15 not only among black
bulls but among all of the magic knights
and villains and black clover is amazing
and the black foals are crushing it in
particular with both of the top two
physically strongest characters coming
from their ranks unfortunately though
when it came to the top five hottest
guys ranking Tabata said that Austin did
not make the cut not that that matters
though when girls like Noel and mimosa
are head over heels for our loudmouth
protagonists fact number 8 in the manga
there are character profiles that
explain some interesting details about a
specific character like birth date for
example since Austin and you know were
orphans who were left at the church for
their birthday we are given the day that
they were found at the church which was
October 4th it seems that they were both
just recently born when they were
brought there since both of them are
still libras perhaps not so
coincidentally the wizard King is also a
Libra being a Libra myself I love the
fact that so many awesome characters in
the show are also born in October and
happened to be libras as well now let's
just ignore the fact that there are also
some unsavory characters in black clover
who are also libras fact number 9
gakuto Kajiwara is the Japanese voice
actor behind haces often loud voice
this is Koji wadis first
major role and honestly the screaming
didn't bother me too much but I know
some people beg to differ
let me know how you feel about koalas
voice acting for hasta in the English
hasta is voiced by the 25 year old
Dallas J Reid who is also best known for
this role in particular you may also
know him as the attack Titan from class
1 B which hasta do you prefer fact
number 10 in lieu of one fact fact 10
will be a lucky lightning round of
random fact because at Anime uproar we
magically make the impossible possible
Ready Set three to one less Jam
Austin's blood type is a he is 155
centimeters tall or 5 foot 1 inches
which means he's shorter than most
he's even shorter than Noel and as a
result has to put up with being called
short stuff on his character profile for
likes Tabata just put sister Lily so
that gives you an idea of how obsessed
he is with her and finally Austin's
initial design sketches were a bit
different than they are now
since he didn't have his signature
headband or too insane muscles that his
current version has and that's it for
today's video thank you so much for
watching I'm so glad that I finally got
around to catching up to black clover
and making a video on it if you want to
see more black clover videos definitely
smash that like button and feel free to
suggest future black clover videos
you're burning up to see in the comments
if you haven't joined the black bowls of
YouTube by attacking that subscribe
button and ringing that magic YouTube
Bell and until next time see ya magic
cowboy
[Music]
you